Now let's discuss the internet
key exchange protocol.
When A and B require IPsec for
traffic between them for the first time.
We do not yet have an SA.
In other words, they have not yet
agreed upon the security parameters.
Such as inclusion and
authentication algorithms and keys.
They need to negotiate these
parameters and store them in an SA.
The Internet Key Exchange Protocol
is for this purpose.
The protocol works in two phases.
The first is to establish an IKE SA.
Because the negotiation of an SA
should itself be protected.
Then this SA is used to protect
the negotiations of multiple IPSec SAs.
The ISA is bi-directional.
That is, it protects the SA
negotiation traffic from both sides.